journée radieuse lviv journée presque
normal pour célébrer le plus beau cadeau
de la vie une naissance
laurence couture gagne on savoure ces
moments trop rare en ukraine avec son
petit léon né il y a deux semaines il
pesait 4 livres on l'a nominée aux parce
que
si le nom de la ville c'était les eaux
police avant qu'on pense qu'elle a
vraiment voulu
messi puis mon grand père s'appelle les
eaux il avait fui kiev avec l'idée de se
rendre en pologne l'accouchement en
temps de guerre dans l'hôpital presque
entièrement déserté de lviv n'aurait pas
pu mieux se passer nous ont mis même au
premier étage avait un peu de protection
donc il voulait pas qu'on soit dans les
étages quatrième étage troisième étage
s'il y avait des bombardements mais le
personnel était calme les médecins aussi
amicaux la ive théâtre de violents
combats et bombardements dans le sud de
l'ukraine chaque naissance est un petit
miracle le sous-sol de l'hôpital a été
aménagé en refuge les accouchements
continue malgré les sirènes d'alarmé
quelques heures après la naissance de
son petit garçon alina se porte bien
elle espère qu'il n'y aura pas trop de
larmes car elle a peur que son bébé
tombe malade il fait froid dans un
sous-sol
risque énorme certaines interventions
doivent quand même être pratiquée en
salle d'opération au premier étage
being
tried to
loin du danger le passage de laurent
salles ville se prolonge impossible
d'obtenir rapidement un document de
voyage canadien pour les os afin d'aller
se réfugier en pologne elle vient
cependant d'obtenir un certificat de
naissance ukrainien après deux semaines
et elle pourra partir mais nous on avait
notre plan d'habiter nous on a un emploi
donc on espère revenir on a un
appartement sa chambre de bébé nos amis
notre réseau social aux cliniques
agréable la résilience prend toutes
sortes de formes en ukraine est ici
philippe leblanc radio canada vivent en
ukraine